you looked at the film and uh let's
start with your boy blue josh allen
how did he pull it off
with a defense that frankly was not good
450 yards allowed no turnovers generated
24 points scored by the colts and it
could have been more running game wasn't
there how does josh allen save the day
under those circumstances well he's just
he's i mean he's in the zone there's no
other way really to say it right now
the way he's playing it just you know
he's he can be surgical if the offense
delivers it
and then his ability to extend plays and
play backyard football
it's arguably as good as anybody in in
the game right now i mean it's right up
there with really mahomes i think
they're the two best backyard football
players in the game
and you know the way they call plays
they put pressure on defenses this was a
tough football game this was a lot of
josh allen they couldn't run the
football he was a leading rusher you
know and of course his throws made the
difference of the game he was absolutely
amazing there's no other way to really
put that mike the colts dominated the
line of scrimmage really on both sides
of the ball they really did they took
your approach which you were all over
last week where they ran the ball and
they tried to run the clock out a little
bit and keep josh allen on the sideline
they knew who they were dealing with and
they did it quite well they really did
the pressure was on josh allen all game
long because their defense was fighting
an uphill battle they couldn't stop the
colts and anything they did but it's
just alan's you know ability especially
you know it's it's about the
game-changing plays you know there's
never empty yards it's never like whoa
he moved the ball between the 30s well
today no he skips right by the 30s and
then gets down to the red zone he's like
here's a ball from the 29 to the 29 zoom
now we're in red zone and here we go but
he just makes so many plays that way i
mean nothing can be more specific to the
end of the first half right the colts
miss the feel or don't go for it they go
for it on fourth to one they don't kick
the field goal they're up ten to seven
he's backed up he runs down the right to
the right sideline and throws an unreal
ball to gabriel davis a few plays later
scrambles left
an unbelievable throw there then he gets
people to jump off sides on a fourth and
three because he's got a hard count
right now that rivals rogers and mahomes
and then he runs the ball in for a
touchdown because inside the 10-yard
line he's almost an unstoppable force
right now with his ability to run throw
and extend plays and it's just uh it was
a great performance is what i'm saying
sorry to blabber so much but you know
giddy up josh allen
he's reached a level of confidence
ability and experience and he's still in
only his third season he's only going to
get better as he has more opportunities
to see defenses to understand how his
skills set
with
the skills of the defensive players and
we see that confidence building and we
see risk-taking but it's in a more
confident yeah and effective way the the
throw to the end zone falling down a
year ago that's a disaster
this year it's a thing of beauty right
it's that simple and it's the product of
just working and working and building
and growing and and getting better and
and
wherever the bills finish this year and
we'll make our picks later this week for
the division around games and i know
chris before the wild card round you
said it would be not a good match up for
the bills to welcome the ravens to town
right out of the gates well they're
welcoming the ravens to town right well
in the second round not right out of the
gates it's not a great matchup it could
end now but the future's bright
they're going to be in the conversation
they're going to be around they're going
to be back because what what the wild
card game proved is
even on a day when nothing else is there
exactly allen is going to make it is
going to make it happen and compensate
for a bad defense and a non-existent
running game
that's right you're right and that
agreed like it's it's you know they got
talent and and young talent at receiver
tight end along with josh allen the
running back like i can't imagine them
going anywhere anytime soon you know not
to say they're going to be a number one
seed in the playoffs year after year
after year but you know with the way
it's set up and some of the pieces they
have in their roster and as talented as
he is yeah i think like like we talked
about a few weeks ago i think he's hit
the stratosphere of the top guys in the
game to where you just go he's on the
field okay they got a chance to win the
football game you know and they you know
the thing i love about buffalo
is
you know they play to his strengths and
they put pressure on you with how they
call the game on the offensive side of
the ball too you know because of the
things you said mike they can trust him
now you know when he does take risks
it's a calculated risk
but they're always attacking because
they can trust hey we can call a bunch
of deep routes and he won't just throw
it no matter what anymore he'll look for
the check down the underneath throw or
buy some time and scramble and wait for
one of those guys to come back and he'll
make a smart decision and they've gotten
to the point too where you know like
even the other day
the hell would like you know let's run
and put the game away no it's throw and
put the game away with josh allen on
them and he doesn't let you off the hook
for anything the best example mike too
is like the stefan diggs touchdown pass
down the right sideline you remember
that in the game you know he's one where
we've talked about in the past with
russell wilson and dk metcalf and some
other guys where you just go
like you can't let teams play man-to-man
on that guy that's you're doing a
disservice to your own team you got to
take advantage if mahomes sees tyree
kill one-on-one he's going gonna exhaust
that until it's like okay fine he's
covered and i can't go to him anymore
and that's the other thing i love about
bill the bills and allen and diggs when
it's one-on-one they go oh you want to
take that chance fine here we go giddy
up it's josh allen and stefan diggs and
we're going to tear you apart and that's
going to make defenses always have to
think twice about ever being aggressive
or leaving him alone you know as far as
stephon diggs is concerned
that's what the ravens defense is going
to have to deal with this weekend and
we're going to talk about lamar jackson
in a second but i just want to press
pause and point out as we search for the
next peyton manning tom brady year after
year it feels inevitable they're going
to meet in the playoffs and we've had
different connections and permutations
of quarterbacks that could give us that
rivalry i think we've lost sight of the
fact i know i have
there's a bunch of great quarterbacks
now i know it doesn't all have to come
down to two no we can have lamar jackson
and josh allen and maybe they won't meet
every year in the playoffs but man when
they do
get ready because it's two great
quarterbacks on the field not at the
same time they eating yeah we know you
know we know the idea right yeah yeah
but
but lamar jackson okay he stepped up got
his first playoff win after uh two years
of being great in the regular season not
great in the postseason he carried over
what he did the final five weeks of the
regular season into the playoffs
what did you see from him
that was different especially from the
home loss to the chargers two years ago
the home loss to the titans last year in
the playoffs well i saw a guy that
didn't panic when they got down like we
saw a little bit last year when they got
down he kind of just started to play
like his hair was on fire and was like
the hell with this i'm gonna go video
game mode and just try to run around and
make some of the damn displays you've
ever seen to try to bring us back and of
course that led to some mistakes too
you know so i think there was a better
understanding of hey let's not panic
let's stay within who we are as a
football team
but you know like i just talked about
with josh allen and we were discussing
you know the big thing is in the big
moments the big guy lamar jackson
made all the big plays you know i think
that's the big thing right off the bat
you know his ability to extend that play
when they were down ten nothing it was
the third nine and he scrambled to the
right coach dungey pointed it out on
sunday night in our pregame
that was a teetering point of the game
where
the titans were in control they drove
the ball the first two times it's ten
nothing
baltimore hadn't showed anything
and that's what a great player does hey
okay settle in everybody i got us i'll
make a play here but i think the big
thing that stuck out to me more than
anything mike we know the running is
special the play making the scrambles
the connection between him and hollywood
brown
that's what i excited me about the game
more than anything with the baltimore
ravens we talked yesterday everybody
knows the ravens have an issue they
don't throw the ball outside the numbers
look at the sprite chart here
it was almost like they they self
scouted myself mike and they went you
know what we do throw the ball over the
middle too much let's have a game where
we actually do the opposite and barely
throw the ball over the middle and you
see here you know all these green dots
all out on the edge a lot of them were
hollywood brown if they can continue
that aspect where lamar can scare
defenses and start to make them respect
like
oh you got to defend out there outside
the numbers and you can't leave
hollywood brown one on one all game long
because he's gonna throw an out route or
a curl route or a slant route that is
gonna make them so much harder to defend
and i think that's the number one thing
that jumped out to me about their game
ravens did an okay job against the run
but
that little aspect helped everything out
just enough when the run wasn't clicking
and hitting on all cylinders to where
they had offense and something to go to
conscious effort to get the ball in the
hands of your playmakers too that's what
we're seeing different from the rave
there's that little flip down to the end
zone it's a little dangerous yeah it's a
little off target could have been a
disaster but you get hollywood brown in
motion coming around you flip the ball
to him technically it's a running play
but come up with ways when you have
weapons get them involved that was the
tweet from hollywood brown that he
deleted after the first loss to the
steelers you've got these great players
why aren't you using them greg roman
waking up finally to the idea that there
are some things that can be done that uh
that really do
it really do
enhance your offense diversify it and
then make it easier for lamar jackson to
do the things he's so good at exactly if
you can draw people away from that
cluster in the middle and they're
worried about the ball going outside the
numbers it's going to be a lot easier to
run it inside the number no doubt you
know you've got to play a guy like sean
mcdermott this week if you're so
predictable to run the ball up the
middle throw the ball over the middle
hey him and leslie frazier are going to
come up with a game plan and go no
you're not going to do that you're going
to have to do something else you know
this is going to have to make them think
twice this week to your point great
offenses make you defend the whole field
and you know you think about the ravens
it's jk dobbins up the middle j.k
dobbins up the middle you know lamar
right off the edge up the middle up the
middle and then you know it's fake those
little runs and over the middle of mark
andrews the tight end and all of that so
defenses can continue to just pack it in
there as games go along and start to
feel comfortable there now
you spread the field a little bit or at
least have the option of hey we'll throw
the ball outside the numbers a little
bit teams will be a little bit you know
scared right to put all their eggs into
let's stop lamar and jk dobbins running
down the middle
i thought it was a great adjustment they
don't need a lot they're very good
football team they're talented
they just need a little schematical
advantage every now and then to give
them a little edge make things a little
easier every now and then so they just
don't always have to blow people off the
line of scrimmage and lamar jackson and
jk dobbins got to make unreal runs
it's going to kill you this week to pick
the ravens over the bills isn't it i
i've been thinking about it the whole
time i don't know where to i don't know
where to go in this one i really don't
it's this is
all these games this week i mean this is
some weekend we got coming up with these
matchups but yeah this one i got my eye
on and it's our game i mean i can't wait
come on nbc saturday night
my boy blue you know
i i'm very excited with what the bills
have done they are the new entry they
are on the scene it's fresh it's fun the
the ravens have it's you know you've had
your chances you blew your games how
much faith we're going to have in you
but i feel like right now
we we said it throughout the month of
december i know no one is going to want
to mess with the ravens in january they
went to tennessee and beat the titans
they made the titans look ordinary they
bottled up derek kennedy i don't want to
get ahead of ourselves but but uh
yeah that's not gonna you're leaning
baltimore it sounds it sounds no matter
what i do
no matter what i do i'm gonna be wrong
uh we all were wrong except for america
and rodney harrison there was a huge
push from america when we did rehearsal
it was only 33 on the browns right then
it was 55 on the browns rodney flipped
from the steelers in rehearsal to the
browns during the game he knew what he
was doing what did you see that the
browns were able to do to allow baker
mayfield to to perform not that he had
to go out and do a josh allen and win
the game that's it but he still had to
not lose the game he had to be confident
he had to keep scoring points when the
steelers finally woke up how did he pull
it off well he played the game the
proper way for what how the game kind of
laid out there in front of him you know
he didn't try to you know do anything
more or try to add to stats or anything
like that hey the game was very
comfortable
for a team that is you know oh man we
haven't been in the playoffs we can't
beat our big brother the pittsburgh
steelers ever
think about you know how great it was
for baker mayfield to go man the first
time i touched the ball we were up seven
nothing and i was on the 46 yard line
going in you know that was a great
confidence builder for a team that's
going wait we didn't practice can we are
we going to be able to beat this team
all of that so all of it you know late
came laid out perfectly for cleveland
but you know i i think like i just think
of little things the first touchdown
pass to jarvis landrieu right mike
remember that little slant route over
the middle and all that
to me
that just shows the
the the maturation of baker mayfield
very similar play route concept and even
defense by the steelers of where baker
mayfield threw a pick six to minka
fitzpatrick earlier in the year when
they went to pittsburgh and play but it
just shows you
what he's seeing on the field he's
seeing it all now he's comfortable it
was a very similar defense the steelers
played a defense to steal away that
slant route from jarvis landry minka
fitzpatrick was right there but what
happened this time is baker had his eyes
all over him so baker is just seeing the
field making the right decisions and
pulling the trigger
where it looks like he's not even
thinking right now it's just coming like
second hand nature and that's what it
looked like throughout the day and as
the game went and they got the lead he
just kept getting the ball okay wait i'm
not gonna be greedy get the ball out of
my hand i'm not gonna let tj watch strip
sack fumble me and turn the tide of the
game or anything like that he managed it
really well
and had the right
you know feel for okay let me take a
little chance here now when it's 35 23
and put the pedal on the metal again to
kind of put our foot back on their
throat i mean really mature performance
by baker mayfield
can i ask you a very important question
of course
what is secondhand nature
it's a new simsism is what it is
yes
no seriously seriously what the hell was
i trying to say there hold on
second nature right second nature second
nature
yes right yeah so second secondhand news
second nature right sure i don't know
that one is truly just dumb that makes
no sense so i don't know about that one
it's been a while you need to get the
reel for 2021 going and it's january
12th so that's good there's another one
i think we have two so far so we'll have
plenty by the time the end of december
rolls around uh by the time the end of
december rolls around tom brady will be
44 almost 44 and a half and still
playing football at a ridiculously high
level
um
it
look it wasn't spectacular on saturday
night and and there was always this
sense of inevitability they were going
to win we were far more fascinated with
taylor heineke i wonder if tom was
miffed at all
some of his reactions were on the
sideline
like everybody's caught up in this guy
that never played before and may never
play again hey i'm tom brady what the
hell but uh what did you see from him
and and and how much of that do you
think translates to this week well i i
think it's still the number the stat
line you see there on the you know our
graphic 22 completions for 381 is what
jumps out to me i know there's you know
18 incompletions there
but i don't really care
because to me what i'm more impressed
with is man 22 completions for almost
400 yards that just tells you when you
know he's throwing the ball and the
guy's catching it it's it's a big play i
mean almost every time it's a it's a
whoa that's a first down whoa that's 15
yards whoa they went for the 40-yard big
one and hit the 25-yard one instead
that's that's what jumps out to me about
them right now
they're just mike it's it's the same
thing we've talked about it's the
protection phenomenal
they do a great job and like we've
talked about all keeping an extra tight
end in or they'll bring in an extra
tackle in the game and have no tight end
of the game so now they have six
offensive linemen across the board and
he'll run a play action but they protect
him up and they are looking to strike
down the field
and really really never were really
stopped throughout this game you know
seven scoring drives only punted i think
four times and really i think three out
of those four times
i looked at it as like uh tampa kind of
messed that drive up i'm not sure i'm
not gonna give washington the credit for
stopping them and last thing here mike
i'm sorry i'm blabbering but i just want
to throw this out there to you too
one of the things i found interesting
about watching the film back i always
look at like
how another team approaches the game
because i like it tells you sometimes
what they think of their own team or how
they match up right and the one thing
early washington tried to run some
different defenses and blitz and do
those type of things
because
i think they yeah they want to give
brady some new looks and he's tom brady
and he's seen every defense in the world
but really i think they started the game
going i don't think our front four can
get there past these big suckers on this
tampa bay offensive line you know and
that's where that's where i found it
interesting too just to go whoa there's
that washington coaching staff that
d-line and i think they even came into
that game going i don't know if we can
get next to him with just these four we
got to maybe send some guys at him every
now and then and i think that just tells
you how they're protecting brady right
now uh as part of the story
can we put the graphic back up again i
did some math and i want to make sure
it's accurate because this really is
phenomenal when you've got 400 yards
right wait 381 yards yeah on 22
completions that's 17.3
yards per completion and even with that
even with 22 of 40 that's not much above
50
right it's still 9.5 yards per attempt
exactly even though
you know
48 49 percent of your throws hit the
ground it's amazing
he had that kind of performance and look
and it also hey he
he he
that's no risk it no biscuit that's
throwing the ball down the field you
know that's uh that's what bruce arians
envisioned
in a weird sort of way when when tom
brady came to town and
if you're blocking those guys and one of
the things aryan said and this gets back
to the whole juju
smith shoes to the browns is the brown
stuff
it wasn't tom brady that necessarily was
motivated by what chase young said last
week it was the offensive line of the
buccaneer yeah that's right said that
after the game they took that to heart
they were motivated by this notion that
this washington defensive line was going
to overpower them and get to tom brady
and they didn't and that allows you to
average 17.3 yards per completion
because you're not dinking and dunking
you're able to get the ball down the
field that that's
it goes back to you know what we said in
the first hour the game is about home
runs and strikeouts now
i just i think we've hit a new era in
cycle and football you know i really do
i think the dink and dunk offense in the
nfl
is slowly dying out you know there's a
lot of empty yards and nothing that
happens there
man did the bucks put pressure on you
would their play calls and the way
they're protecting brady right now and
the way he's throwing the football
you know again other than josh allen i'd
go this is the best downfield passing
attack in the league other than that
what we got in buffalo so that's how
special it is and you know you said the
no risk it no biscuit thing mike
one thing i've thought of recently you
know it they've done a phenomenal job
getting tom to be comfortable to throw
the ball down the field and feel
comfortable in the pocket they really
have that's where byron left which bruce
arians they deserve a lot of credit
because that was something brady was
reluctant to do the last few years in
new england and uh they changed him that
way
and when you consider their style and
who they're playing on sunday night for
the third time this year a team that has
beaten the buccaneers twice the new
orleans saints they are still infield
single
hitters yes and they'll dink and dunk
and they'll make it work and and it will
be the matchup of the oldest
quarterbacks in nfl history when buying
it 85 years old and tom brady posted
this this is awesome now
i say that brady looks like david
letterman twitter says that drew brees
looks like the dad from family ties that
may be both for your time no i know yes
he does he looks a lot like the dad of
uh you know uh what what's his you know
what's his name alex p keaton right
michael j michael j fox thank you very
much it very much i could see both of
those yes brady does look like letterman
there very similar that's really good
and that's cool they both they both had
some fun with it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports